more than 40 leaders from around Europe
are in Prague for the first meeting of
the new European political Community now
this is an EU initiative that brings
together EU Leaders with countries
beyond the blocks borders including
Britain turkey Ukraine Switzerland and
Norway and it takes place as Europe
battles an energy crisis and economic
turmoil that's been worsened by Russia's
war in Ukraine we'll hear from our
correspondent in Prague in just a moment
first this on this new political format
this is where the European Union's
leaders assemble when they meet in
Brussels the 27 seats at this table
represent more than 450 million people
in Europe
it's a club some neighboring countries
on the continent have been waiting
decades to join but the requirements to
qualify for EU membership makes the
process both long and slow
so when France's president Emmanuel
macron introduced the idea of the
European political Community there were
immediate concerns from some that it was
somehow a second tier substitute to EU
membership
let's bring Europe together on the basis
of its geography on the basis of
democratic values with a desire to
preserve the unity of our continent
and we also want to preserve the
strength and ambition of our integration
joining wouldn't mean in the future you
couldn't join the European Union
and it also wouldn't be limited to those
who have left the European Union
the new European political Community or
EPC will be made up of 44 countries
these include the 27 EU member states
countries who don't want to be in the EU
like Norway and Switzerland
those that do
and the one that recently left
you've got to hand it to the eu's
leadership for getting an RSVP from
everybody that they invited to join the
European political community
but there is still the feeling that the
purpose of the format is far from clear
and with so many nations gathered at the
table some of them friends and some of
them foes the Skeptics are doubtful
about what the EPC can accomplish and
whether it will be anything more than
just another Talk Shop this is about
diplomacy in a different route this is
about making sure we keep our neighbors
and our enemies close and making sure we
speak to them on a regular basis and
people will genuinely feel is it
possible to have a conversation of this
nature with that kind of difference and
that kind of difference a difference in
ideology and I think the only good thing
about this is is making sure we keep
diplomatic channels open the EU council
president Charles Michelle will leave
the discussions at the first European
political community meeting in Prague
there won't be a formal declaration
issued after the summit but should this
first one go down well the aim would be
for the leaders to gather once or twice
a year
okay
let's joined DW's Brussels bureau chief
Alexandra Von Norman who is in Prague
for that meeting welcome Alexandra so
help us understanding help us understand
what this European political Community
is is it EU light or EU XXL
well none of the above at least that is
what European officials have been
telling us and that ah they are at pain
to point out that the U is just
facilitating this event that it is not a
EU driven process it's more about
leaders coming together to discuss
common interests and issues that matter
to them but of course you can ask why do
you need another platform like that we
already have structures like that for
instance the organization for cooperate
for security and cooperation in Europe
and this is quite a risky thing to hold
an event like that because you'll risk
alineating some states for instance
those in the western Balkans who have
been waiting for decades to join the
European Union and they fear now that
this event this community could be a
consolation price for then of course as
mentioned in the the report that our
other countries they don't have any
aspirations to join the union the UK
left the European Union and they are
also very cautious they do not like this
title European community and still we
have to say that the fact that more than
40 leaders will be here today is very
telling it's showing that there is a
huge interest in such a platform
so given all those question marks and
the huge interest what does this today's
Summit actually hope to achieve
well actually the goal here is to have
this event in the first place as one
Diplomat put it it's a to about bringing
leaders on equal footing to foster a
political dialogue and of course when we
see what challenges at the continent is
facing it is important there is a war
raging in Ukraine a war that has an
impact on every almost every aspect of
our life so the fact that despite
Vladimir Putin's
attempts to exploit divisions on the
continent the fact that we have all that
leaders here today is a very symbolic
gesture
Alexandra Von Norman in Prague thank you